[Music]  you're after something  [Music]  is it revenge  money  what is it something else you look good  little rough around the edges but good  heard about a job big shot gangster  putting together crew  I'm a driver and I'm a flier  the waited a long time for a shot like  this  what do you think well what did you know  you got a land on the ship  yeah no guy either by smugly around I  heard a story about you I was wondering  if it's true everything you've heard  about me it's true l-3 let's go with a  mean man's face who are these guys  if you come with us you're in this life  for good my wanna [ __ ] a lot baby  [Music]  let me give you some advice assume  everyone will betray you  and you will never be disappointed  I got a really good feeling about this  when you know how to fly me a hundred  and ninety years old  good great  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]